we must protect the american hamburger  at all costs  how do we do that burger scholar  sessions  with me  burger scholar session season two with  me george moats what's gonna happen on  this season an  homage to some classics but also some  burgers you've never seen before  they're going to seem kind of weird you  have to understand though that you must  trust me  i've had these burgers i've been in  these regions i've been in these  restaurants  and they are all amazing let's make a  burger  [Music]  you hear that that's the sound of  happiness right there  whoa it's one of those burgers that i  really dream about  all the time it has a  very interesting backstory with all  kinds of twists  wow  oh [ __ ] this is america right here  you also need some coleslaw now oh no  oh my god that's delicious butter has a  condiment butter  nailed that one  [Music]  so stop watching this and go make one  now you can do it  burger scholar session season two with  me george moats